i think with any job that you take on
there's always going to be this period
where people need to know who you are
and i think you have to reveal yourself
in some ways
because you really need to earn that
respect from your staff they have to
know who they're
fighting with and who they're fighting
for
and the things that you believe in and
what ultimately
you know they are signing on for that
will hopefully take you to the promised
land which for us is a world
championship
my name is kim eng general manager of
the miami marlins
in terms of the road that led here was
probably over the course of about 15
years
definitely more than 10 interviews with
many other clubs it was a long and
arduous
process you know i think to be rejected
that many times
is tough on anybody's ego but i think at
the end of the day
it's really hard to lose hope in your
dreams and you just have to keep pushing
on
in terms of this stage i just feel a lot
more wise
than i was 10 20 years ago i think i've
seen a lot more
the experiences are rich and
deep and so i think you know when you
get to this point in your career in your
life
i think you just have a better
understanding for people what they go
through
the trials and tribulations and again
trying to get everybody on the same page
and how much that really means
you just absolutely have to keep going
after it and you know look at a certain
point
you know we all come come to doubt
ourselves um
but you know i think that those are also
points for reflection
and for really getting it gaining a deep
understanding of what is important to
you
and it's at those times where you make
those choices and you decide whether to
just
keep pursuing or you know take a break
but i think you never lose sight of
those dreams
you